in the the fight this weekend i did
watch oh did you watch it i watched just
the main event
yeah i have a privilege i have two
questions for you
that and by the way people listening i'm
not
i'm a i mean average fan so i'm going to
ask some average fan questions
how come so he was saying that he
couldn't see out of his left eye
so as soon as you can't see out of your
left eye and you're fighting
arguably one of the best heavyweights of
all time yes yes
you know you can't win at this point not
necessarily but also
but your left eye is your lead and it's
also with the right hand
yeah but what do you like the world
titles on the line so you gotta
fight through it but also the ref [ __ ]
up because there's a point where
danny cormay goes i can't see right the
wh
the few things you never say inside that
gun unless you have a serious issue is
if you say i can't see the fight should
be stopped
dc goes i got poke deny and the ref goes
now is a punch sit down you're all right
it's like well you didn't see it dude so
look at that
so this is what i'm saying right so is
it isn't he he's
he's not a young dude no 41. 41.
hold on 41 olympian wrestler uh former
grand p
grand prix strike force world champion
light heavyweight champion ufc
heavyweight champion of c if that guy
goes hey dude
i got poked in the eye i'm gonna go he
got poked in the eye that's what i'm
saying if michael jordan goes hey dude
shoot like this i'm going to shoot like
this there's certain you got to listen
to what these [ __ ]
goats character is unquestionable
yes yes one of the best of all time but
so i'm and
nobody doesn't like dc i know i'm going
to hear a lot of hey you [ __ ]
man up no no no but at that age
at 41 accomplish what he's accomplished
fighting
arguably one of the best heavyweights
about that fight was to decide who's
gonna be the best
okay am i risking
permanent permanent damage without being
able to see out of that lead
it's happening guys like michael bisping
he he this
he got hit with a wheel kick i think
from vtor and it you know it ruined his
eye he was
basically blind in his eye if he had
tapped out if he had just said man i
just can't do it
would be they would have stopped the
fight and i i think chin i think this
they would have stopped the fight
there and then went from the score the
judges from there
so dc probably would have won or if he
couldn't continue they might actually
just
because it isn't a legal thing yeah if
they considered an actual purposely
you know poking in the eye but that but
to do to be fair to dc that's probably
what should have been
done but that's what i'm saying like and
if he says i can't go any further
as a fake guy dude it's so crazy is he
being called a giant [ __ ]
today no if he says i can't go anything
i don't think so because when they show
that replay and it's not like
i'm not going to usually it's like you
know like oh come on
dude a knuckling again you're it's case
by case the ref should know who you're
dealing with if it's down in cormier
one of the greatest to ever do it goes
dude i got poked an eye
my initial reaction be like he really
got poked in the eye not
sit down dude it was a punch oh was it
how many fights have you been in dude
okay it's dc
man so here's my next question and um
this is always
fascinating to me to ask athletes this
question so now i can't see
someone ask you first if you were going
to rank in order of importance
and let's assume everyone's a
professional athlete so if in order of
importance
confidence training heart
and skill when you're in that fight now
they're both professionals so skill
level is all
around the same yeah what in order of
importance what goes first
in that fight i would say confidence
because the
you don't get to that level and not have
heart you don't get that low not have
skill
i'd say if anything the one thing that's
going to waver and that's confidence
when you have one eye your game plan is
going to be different that's what i'm
saying the whole thing
makes up so i'm not taking anything away
from stipe because he fought a great
fight and
you know dc continue on it is what it is
but
the guy's compromise when he has one eye
dude imagine doing anything with one eye
cover your eye like this and drive home
it's a nightmare dude i tried i'll fight
the grace heavyweight of all time with
one eye i tried to brush my teeth
i was like is it how hard oh dude nice
yeah i
scraped i went in too deep like so
that's my question so if confidence
being number one
in that at that level of confidence and
i've already taken now and
now that you can't see and you've said i
can't see i am assuming also
the other fighter's confidence goes up
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
so what do we do like why doesn't the
coroner throw in a towel why doesn't
like i don't understand because if the
corner throws in the towel then you just
you then the fight's over and you lost
the fight you need the ref to step
in and what's weird is they does he have
a family
cormier oh yeah so that would have been
it for me i think i think and again
this dude there they have different dna
they have different dna than me just
being a fighter look if you told me
every day
hey you're going to go to work and get
punched i'd be like i need a new job
it's a tough gig
but on top of that now i'm fighting
somebody who could not just damage my
eye
but damage my life especially at 41.
life
again though if you go back in time sure
mark goddard would have stopped the
fight had the doctor come in
i guarantee you they would have stopped
that fight i'm fascinated by what
i'm fat i'm fascinated by what keeps him
fighting well that's what makes him the
one the grace of all time yeah
you know you're talking about a guy who
was successful at every level he's an
olympian and nothing has to prove he
doesn't know anything left
no he's a light heavyweight champ
already he was a heavyweight champ
already like there's
this is just cement his legacy is the
greatest of all time it's his last fight
that he's gonna to do
here's something about dc2 he so he used
to have three kids one of the kids
passed away oh no way dude so so that
weighs on me too so say i'm in the ring
and now i could be not be the same
person i was walking into the ring for
my two kids
because i can't see to the other end of
that
let's say he won that fight with the one
eye then you're considered the greatest
of all time
it's such a fast here's what's weird
about him is he's also the best analyst
they have besides joe rogan
daniel cormay is hands down the best
answer they have on
deck why why he's amazing he's so good
at it
and he'll do it till his [ __ ] beard
grows in gray
that's his that's his gig i don't know
how much to paint him right but he's set
man he has another
his his whole life is already planned
out he's good you know what's
interesting to me is that so this dude
who is in our conversation for greatest
heavyweight of all time
but yet your casual fan like myself
doesn't know that much about him because
his personality is more reserved
it's not like a connor or you know some
of these other loud guys
yeah so like are you thinking about
stipe
cb's a full-time firefighter bro like
the greatest heavyweight at all times he
is a firefighter
doesn't doesn't take any time he's a
firefighter year-round he's a piece of
part-time working on full-time but he is
still a firefighter all your own so but
so he's nuts
these guys the it's almost like you are
not rewarded for what my dad would say
doing it the right way
but in order to get the mayday you have
to be
connor you have to be floyd mayweather
well no
well those get well listen they didn't
make there's only one conor mcgregor but
i mean you have to but there's a guy out
there
no other guy like khabib who's the
highest paid fighter in the
in the ufc now and he's super respectful
doesn't talk [ __ ] is he the highest paid
yeah now he is yeah
i mean if conor decided to come back he
would be the highest paid being
right now but as far as contractually
khabib's the highest paid guy
and he is by the book usada can test him
every day of the week his fights are fun
to watch
yes i do too i really are fun to watch
because he does one thing
i love greatness he does one thing so
great that nobody can figure out me too
i'm gonna tune in
every [ __ ] until somebody figures it
out same with floyd mayweather people
like his fights are boring i'm like hit
him
yeah that i love seeing [ __ ] i like
people trying to figure out the puzzle
me i i might do are you probably not are
you into f1 racing no
like uh hamilton is like no
i mean he's just so much better than
everybody and me and my brother watch it
and i said
my brother like i mean we know
hamilton's gonna win but who gives a
[ __ ] he's like
because it's fun to see like you're
watching the michael jordan of race car
driving
tiger he's so much better than ever when
i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son